-I want to talk
about Donald Trump
because in 2011 I hosted
the White House
Correspondents´ Dinner.
-Yes.
-I told some jokes about him.
But that year,
you actually emceed --
people forget this happened
very, like, soon before.
You did the Comedy Central
"Roast of Donald Trump"...
-That´s right.
-...when you emceed it.
And he actually seemed to be
a pretty good sport.
Certainly a better sport there
than he was a few months later.
What was your memory
of that night?
-I -- you know,
the strange thing was,
I-I have the same thought,
like he´s --
he´s taken all this.
The only thing I think we
weren´t allowed to joke about
was the bankruptcy.
-Yeah.
-Bankruptcies.
-Mm-hmm.
-Everything else was kind of
on the table.
That was the one thing he was
sensitive about. And I just --
-I guess that´s the one
that goes the farthest
against what he
presents himself as.
-Yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
-But I just remember thinking,
"man, this guy is really
freaking boring."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-This is...
-Like, in your interactions
with him?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-It´s like this guy´s just
really dull and it´s -- it´s --
it´s, you know,
I meet -- businessmen at that
level that I´ve met in the past,
it´s kind of the same reaction.
It´s like they´re just --
they just seem like dull guys.
-Yeah. And dull guys --
-And unfortunately, yeah.
-Dull guys don´t make
for great roast -- ´cause they
actually, they finished.
They closed the night.
-Yeah.
I mean, every joke that -- that
we told, you know, it´s like,
hey, Donald Trump...you know,
I don´t know what the hell
the joke was, when he has sex,
he closes his eyes and imagines
himself jerking off.
[ Laughter ]
And I look over -- and that joke
and every -- I look over
and Trump´s face is like...
[ Laughter ]
It´s like -- kind of like, "all
right, I´ll give him that one."
-Yeah.
-So -- so not the same guy
that he seems to be now.
-No, he´s -- he´s turned --
he´s evolved?
-Mm
[ Laughter ]
-So...
-Yeah.
-Congratulations, "Family Guy´s"
16th season.
-Yeah.
-That´s amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-And, you know, it´s everywhere.
-Yep, yep, yep.
-The show is everywhere,
multiple countries and --
which is nice and easy when you
have an animated show,
´cause you just have people
re-record...
-Right.
-...in their language.
But are there jokes
that you make
that do not translate
into other languages?
-I -- there -- there have to be.
-Yeah.
-There have to be. The show has
weird titles elsewhere.
I was told that in Korea
the show is called,
"The Shocking Family."
-Oh, well...
[ Laughter ]
-That´s the title of the show.
-I like that they were worried
that people would see it
as, like, guidance if they
didn´t call it that.
-Yeah, exactly --
-Like this is a regular family.
-Yeah, so I don´t know.
I don´t know.
And that kind of gives
everything away up front.
-Do you ever get to hear --
like, do they run by,
"hey, here´s the voice
of the person in Korea
who´s going to do
the characters"?
-You know, they -- they...
[ Laughs ] they don´t.
-Yeah.
-They don´t.
And I -- I don´t -- you know,
like every once in a while,
I´ll catch a clip of,
like, "Family Guy" or "Ted"
in German and it´s like Peter,
but he´s like...
[ Imitating German ]
[ Laughter ]
And it´s like, that wow --
that -- I don´t know what´s
going on. I don´t know how
the show is perceived there.
-Do you -- when you hear it,
do you have an appreciation
where you say,
"that´s a pretty good
German Peter"?
-I´m just glad somebody else is
worrying about it.
-Yeah, that´s -- I liked. Yeah.
Micromanaging, that is --
that´s a loser´s game.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You -- these characters, these
voices, do you just sort of,
like, talk until you find
something you like
or are they based on people?
-You know, it´s -- they come
from different places.
I mean, Stewie, as I´ve said
in the past,
is based on Rex Harrison.
-Mm-hmm.
-He´s the character actor
from those Henry Higgins.
Peter was based on a
security guard that I went to --
you know, worked at my college,
at the Rhode Island
School of Design.
[ Laughter ]
-Does he know this?
-I think he -- I -- they don´t
know which one,
and I´ve never kind of made
it clear which one.
-[ Laughs ]
-There´s a very specific guy,
but they all -- there´s actually
several of them, you know,
are like, "oh, yeah,
that´s me he´s talking about."
[ Laughter ]
-And do you think -- do you
think when he says that
and people hear it, they go,
"oh, it is you"?
Do you think it -- is it that
close to him
that they would say --
-It´s -- it´s -- yeah, yeah,
it´s possible.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-You know what?
They´re a lovely bunch of guys,
if I can make them all happy
believing
that they´re all Peter.
-[ Laughs ] That´s true.
-Then that makes me happy.
-And so obviously you were
a Rhode Island School of Design
artist before anything else.
Pretty much, right?
-Yeah, yeah, I was --
-And you -- I was hearing that
your first cartoon actually got
you in trouble, which sort of --
certainly trends towards
a guy who makes a show called
"The Shocking Family."
-Yes, yes.
-What was your early cartoon
and your early complaint?
-Shockingly, I-I-I wanted to
work for Disney
when I was at the --
in college...
[ Laughter ]
...if you can believe that.
-Yeah.
-And then that --
-That would have been
a whole different --
-That went away.
-Yeah.
-And... [ Laughs ]
-And, no, I got a-a hate letter
from the town priest
for doing a --
[ Laughter ]
-Can it be a hate letter
from a --
-Well, I don´t know. You know,
listen, I was doing comics
for a local paper.
I was 10-years-old,
getting a letter from
a priest -- wait a second.
[ Laughter ]
Um...
Hang on. It just -- the --
you know, I was 10.
The cartoon was a guy getting
communion at church and he says,
"can I have fries with that?"
You know?
-Yeah.
-10-years-old.
-10-years-old,
that´s such a very --
-Yeah.
-That´s a really good, edgy,
10-year-old joke....
-Sure, absolutely.
-...that anybody 14 or over
should not be offended by it.
-Yeah, no, it´s fine. It´s fine.
You might see it
in "Family Circus."
-Yeah.
-But, yeah, the letter said,
"shame on you for insulting
the Almighty God
and those who love Him."
-Wow!
-Yeah, yeah.
-That sounds like a priest who
has been asked a few times,
"can I have fries with this?"
Yeah.
-Exactly.
And from that point on,
I knew exactly
what I wanted to do
with my life.
-And when -- how far,
like, were you still --
Disney was actually when
you were at RISD?
-At college, yeah, yeah.
-And like when did you realize,
"oh, this isn´t gonna --
I shouldn´t do Disney."
-You know -- it was two-fold.
I started doing stand-up.
-Uh-huh.
-And was getting laughs
with a certain type of material,
and I thought,
"well, that -- this isn´t going
to fly there."
-Yeah.
-And then "The Simpsons"
obviously reinvented
the whole ball game and --
-Yeah.
-Oh, God, you can --
cartoons are once again
not just for kids,
so it was two-fold.